[Musik]
es handelt sich um kein Geheimnis in den
wohlhabendsten Ländern der Welt bekommen
immer weniger Menschenkinder und die die
welche bekommen bekommen immer weniger
davon die sinkenden Geburtenraten sind
praktisch ein allgemeines Phänomen in
der gesamten entwickelten Welt es
scheint klar zu sein dass dies in naher
Zukunft eine der größten
Herausforderungen sein wird wir sprechen
von Ländern die das Rückgrat der
Weltwirtschaft bilden jedoch immer älter
werden und immer weniger Kinder haben
tatsächlich liegen die meisten reichen
Industrieländer bereits weit unter der
Ersatzrate das heißt sie liegen unter
den 2,1 Kindern pro Frau nötig wären um
die Bevölkerung zumindest stabil auf
demselben Niveau zu halten wenn man die
Einwanderung außen vor lässt bei diesen
Gesellschaften handelt es sich aus
biologischer und evolutatorischer Sicht
also um die ineffizientesten
Populationen die es jemals auf dem
Planeten gegeben hat denn sie
produzieren mit den meisten Ressourcen
die wenigsten neuen Menschen es gibt
jedoch einen besonderen Fall ein Land
das wirklich alle Rekorde Bericht wo die
durchschnittliche Kinderzahl pro Frau
nicht nur weniger als zwei Kinder pro
Frau beträgt seine weniger als ein Kind
wir sprechen von dem Land mit der
niedrigsten Geburtenrate der Welt und ja
wie ihr vielleicht schon anhand des
Titels dieses Videos erraten hat spreche
ich von Südkorea setzt euch einfach nur
an konkret sprechen wir von einer
Fruchtbarkeitsrate von nur 0,78 Kindern
pro Frau im Jahr 2022 ein wird der so
niedrig liegt dass man fast sagen könnte
dass Kinder kriegen in Südkorea sei eine
Anomalie geworden und Achtung denn in
Sol ist die Rate sogar noch niedriger
wir sprechen hier von nur 0,59 Kindern
pro Frau das ist sage und schreibe nur
eine Viertel der Ersatzrate eine viertel
und alle die nur ein wenig über
exponentialrechnung Wissen verstehen
sofort was für eine Katastrophe die ist
darstellt mit anderen Worten in diesem
Fall ist es nicht bloß so das Südkorea
einen demokratischen Winter durchmacht
sondern dass wir praktisch vor der
Chronik eines vorhersagbaren Aussterben
stehen
obwohl Südkorea eines der reichsten und
fortschrittlichsten Länder der Welt es
steht es vor einem kolossalen Problem
dessen Lösung alles andere als einfach
ist und das in diesem Land eine nie da
gewesene demografische Katastrophe
auslösen könnte aber nicht nur eine
demografische Katastrophe denn wenn sich
die Dinge nicht schnell ändern
vielleicht auch eine wirtschaftliche
selbst bei einer starken robotisierung
der Industrie und Steigerung der
Produktivität ist es möglich dass es ein
kurzer Zeit nicht mehr genug
Arbeitskräfte gibt um die Wirtschaft am
Laufen zu halten dann gibt es in
Südkorea einfach nicht mehr genug
Menschen um ihre Fabriken ihre Geschäfte
ihre Schulen und Unternehmen aller Art
zu betreiben
und nein der übertreiben an dieser
Stelle ganz und gar nicht werft mal
einen Blick auf diese Grafik ist euch
klar was das bedeutet was ihr hier seht
ist die Bevölkerungsprognose Südkoreas
für den nächsten Jahrzehnte wie ihr
erkennen könnt ist es gut möglich dass
das Land erworben Stelle bereits heute
sein historisches bevölkerungsmaximum
erreicht hat von nun an wird die
Bevölkerung nicht nur viel älter sein
sondern sie wird auch in ihrer
Gesamtzahl abnehmen und glaubt nicht
dass das so langsam vor sich gehen wird
das ist niemanden richtig betrifft in
den nächsten 40 Jahren wird dieses Land
mehr als 12 Millionen Einwohner
verlieren das sind 25% aller gesamten
Bevölkerung demografisch gesehen ist das
schon ein normal historisch nie da
gewesener Rückgang und selbst das ist
noch nicht alles wenn der aktuelle Trend
anhält wird die Bevölkerung Südkoreas
bis zum Ende des Jahrhunderts
voraussichtlich auf weniger als die
Hälfte schrumpfen von heute fast 52
Millionen Einwohner auf knapp 20
Millionen es gibt kein anderes Land auf
der Welt mit so schlechten
demografischen Aussichten wir sprechen
über ein Szenario in denen nicht nur die
Hälfte des Südkoreaner verschwinden wird
sondern auch eine großer Teil des
Wohlstands vernichtet werden könnte so
dass die verbliebenen enorme
Schwierigkeiten bekommen
[Musik]
wenn sich die aktuellen Prognosen
bewahrheiten werden die Kinder die heute
geboren werden ihr Land mit der Hälfte
der Bevölkerung erleben wenn sie in
Rente gehen und zwar mit allem was
dazugehört das heißt mehr Sozialausgaben
weniger Wettbewerbsfähigkeit weniger
Ersparnisse weniger Konsum und so weiter
und so fort und vergisst bitte nicht
dass wir hier nicht nur über eine Waage
Hypothese sprechen sondern über einen
Prozess der bereits begonnen hat
schlimmer noch ein Prozess der sich
bereits jenseits des points auf
Norwegian das Punkt ohne Wiederkehr
befindet nach Jahren mit einem absoluten
Geburtenrückgang gibt es im Land bereits
viele Fälle in denen Grundschulen
Geburtshilfe und Kinderkrankenhäuser und
andere Einrichtungen geschlossen werden
müssen
und viele von euch werden sich an dieser
Stelle fragen warum um alles in der Welt
passiert das in einem Land in dem die
Wirtschaft angeblich boomt und es sind
Menschen materiell an nichts mangelt was
genau sind die Gründe warum Südkoreaner
keine Kinder mehr haben wollen was
unternimmt die Regierung um diese
Situation zu ändern hat sie eine Lösung
parat gibt es überhaupt eine Lösung im
heutigen Video werden wir diese und
weitere hochgradig kritische Fragen
beantworten lasst uns aber vorher noch
einen wichtigen werbeshinweis
einspielen damit wir danach sofort
fortfahren können denn zur BPN ist ein
wirklich empfehlenswertes und sicheres
VPN welches z.B keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit lockt natürlich
kann ein Virtual Private nett vor allem
Gefahren schützen die man muss nach wie
vor unsichthalten lassen und wissen was
man tut aber stellt hier für ein
Werkzeug mit gleich mehreren Vorteilen
da zum einen erschwert ist in
Kombination mit anderen Vorkehrungen
eure Aktionen müssen nachzuverfolgen und
abzuhören mit Hilfe verschiedener
Sicherheit könnt ihr so eure eine nettet
im Netz erhöhen z.B mit den integrierten
Kinder das alle unerwünschten Cookies
und Popups blockt weiterer Vorteile dass
sie tun könnt als während ihr an einem
anderen Ort so könnt ihr zum Beispiel
auf Webseite und Internetdienste
zugreifen im Land in mir gerade seitlich
verfügbar werden ob daheim oder im
Urlaub damit schlagt jetzt hinzu und
georg-blocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix
und andere streamiddienste die ihre
Inhalte nur in den USA Anbieten von
Europa ausnutzen oder deutsches
Internetfernsehen im Ausland gucken mit
Surfer kein Problem aber das ist noch
lange nicht alles immer nur eines
wirklich alle eure Endgeräte evpn
registrieren Handys Notebooks oder sogar
euren Smart TV so und wenn ihr den
Rabattcode politik.de angeht bekommt ihr
von uns oder frag auch noch einen Rabatt
in Höhe von 83% und obendrein die ersten
drei Monate gratis dazu den Link zu
diesem Angebot findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video also
nicht viel los besorgt damit
gleichzeitig auch uns finanzielle unter
die Arme das könnt ihr auch direkt mit
Hilfe eines Spenden links den ich euch
ebenfalls in die Beschreibung gepackt
habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung dankbar denn damit hättet
ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere Videos zu liefern so und
nun lasst uns zur Geschichte eines
Landes zurückkehren das auf seine eigene
Auslöschung zu steuert aufgepasst
die vier nein
[Musik]
wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt ist eine
Katastrophe wie die die wir hier
beschreiben nicht etwas das einfach so
passiert es gibt eine Menge verschiedene
Gründe dafür und diese sind nicht immer
leicht zu erklären aber hier auch
visualpolitik werden wir versuchen sie
euch so kurz und informativ wie möglich
zu vermitteln am einfachsten wäre es
natürlich die Schuld auf niedrige Löhne
den übersteigerten Wettbewerb ins
Südkorea oder darauf zu schieben dass
Frauen sich lieber auf ihre Karriere
konzentrieren als diese zu gefährden um
Kinder zu bekommen aber nein auch wenn
diese Faktoren mit beantwortet sind
erklären sie nicht warum Südkorea das
Land mit der niedrigsten Geburtenrate
der Welt ist schließlich treffen diese
Faktoren auch auf andere Länder zu was
hat also dazu geführt dass das Problem
in Südkorea ein solches Ausmaß
angenommen hat
nun ich kann euch schon im Voraus
verraten dass euch einige Dinge die
jetzt kommen schockieren werden
einerseits ist die südkoreanische
Gesellschaft vielleicht eine der
konservativsten und traditionellsten
aller entwickelten Länder und ich ahne
was ihr an dieser Stelle denkt
konservative gesellschaftschaften diese
haben doch normalerweise einen Vorteil
wenn es um die Geburtenrate geht oder
nicht nun wie sich herausstellt nicht
immer eines der Probleme die sie im Land
der Morgenstille haben ist ihre extrem
puritanische und traditionelle Art
Mutterschaft und Familienmodelle zu
verstehen tatsächlich gibt es praktisch
nur ein einziges Familienmodell das
zwischen einer Frau und einem Mann und
dann natürlich die Kinder alles wirklich
alles was außerhalb dieses Rahmens liegt
wird effektiv aus dem System
ausgeschlossen und die südkoreanische
Gesellschaft verliert viele
Möglichkeiten ihr großes Problem der
Kinderlosigkeit zu lösen oder zumindest
zu mildern aber da ich weiß dass das was
ich gerade gesagt habe überraschen sein
können und einige von euch
wahrscheinlich gibt es sind werde ich
euch Daten und konkrete Beispiele geben
[Musik]
in Südkorea wurden im Jahr 2021 nur 2,9%
der Babys unehelich geboren während der
OECD Durchschnitt bei haltet euch fest
rund 40% liegt also 16 Mal höher das
heißt diese Kinder fast 40% werden in
Südkorea einfach nicht geboren mit
anderen Worten in der südkoreanischen
Gesellschaft ist es undenkbar ohne eine
traditionelle Ehe Kinder zu bekommen
verheiratet zu sein ist eine
Voraussetzung um eine Familie zu haben
und nein das liegt nicht daran dass die
Südkoreaner besonders religiös oder
gesellschaftlich ganz anders wären als
wir oder sie einfach mehr Lust auf die
Ehe hätten denn wie ich euch bereits
gesagt habe das ist nicht der Fall es
handelt sich an erster Stelle um eine
kulturelle Angelegenheit
[Musik]
alleinerziehende Mütter werden in dieser
Gesellschaft in der die Ehe und das was
die Leute sagen immer noch eine riesige
Rolle spielt einfach verurteilt in
Südkorea ist es schlicht und einfach
verpönt ein außer ähnliches Kind zu
bekommen man ist gebrannt Markt und das
Kind auch mit gleichgeschlechtlichen
Ehen wollen wir an dieser Stelle erst
gar nicht anfangen im Allgemeinen werden
all diese Dinge in Südkorea als schlecht
für Kinder angesehen aber obwohl sich
die Kinder in den übrigen
Industrieländern nicht so schlecht zu
entwickeln scheinen wollen wir in diesem
Video nicht über Familienmodelle
diskutieren sondern viel mehr über die
Auswirkungen dieser starren Haltung auf
die Geburtenrate
tatsache ist nämlich dass all dieser
kulturelle druckfrauen dazu zwingend
eine Entscheidung zu treffen um jeden
Preis irgendeinen Ehemann zu finden um
Kinder bekommen zu können oder auf dem
motorschaft zu verzichten und sich voll
auf sich selbst und die berufliche
Karriere zu konzentrieren und ja genau
das tun dann viele Frauen sie
entscheiden sich für die zweite Option
wir werden euch später genau erklären
warum fakt ist dass dadurch immer
weniger Frauen bereit sind überhaupt
Kinder zu bekommen was logischerweise
dazu beiträgt dass die Geburtenrate auf
einem Tiefpunkt liegt okay so weit so
schlecht aber wartet ein Moment denn es
gibt nicht nur schlechte Nachrichten
denn zum Glück können sich
gesellschaftlich auch ändern und
anpassen und nach und nach akzeptieren
dass immer mehr Menschen die
Mutterschaft außer der traditionellen
Ehre realisiert so ist auch in Südkorea
die Akzeptanz von Alleinerziehenden in
den zehn Jahren zwischen 2012 und 2022
um mehr als 12 Punkte gestiegen von
knapp 22 auf 35% der Befragten aber der
Staat und öffentliche Institutionen sind
viel langsamer bei diesen Fortschritten
das südkore frische Mutter und Kind
Gesundheitsgesetz zum Beispiel bezieht
sich in seiner Definition von
Unfruchtbarkeit ausdrücklich auf ein
verheiratetes Paar das heißt wenn eine
Frau nicht verheiratet ist hat sie keine
Möglichkeit Unterstützung für eine
Fruchtbarkeitsbehandlung zu erhalten das
System schließt alleinstehende Frauen
vom Zugang zu Fruchtbarkeitsbehandlung
oder in vitrovertisation aus
[Musik]
außerdem besagt das südkoreanische
Bioethik und Sicherheitsgesetz dass
jeder der eine
initroverisationsbehandlung durchführen
möchte die Zustimmung seines Partners
haben muss mit anderen Worten es gibt
als selbstverständlich dass diese
Behandlungen ausschließlich Paaren
vorbehalten sind alleinstehende Frauen
mit Fruchtbarkeitsproblemen haben von
vornherein keine Chance und dies ist ein
Teufelskreis denn in einer konservativen
Gesellschaft wenn eine solche Frau
vielleicht auch kein Mann heiraten und
nicht nur das abgesehen von der
Gesetzeslage stellt sich auch die
südkoreanische Kirche vehement gegen
diese Art von Behandlung für
unverheiratete Frauen vergessen nicht
dass wir übereinander sprechen in dem
die Beziehungen zwischen Politikern und
Religionsgemeinschaften normalerweise
sehr eng sind
und all das wird noch wichtiger wenn wir
ein weiteres Problem berücksichtigen mit
dem sich junge südkoreanische Frauen
heute nicht auseinandersetzen wollen im
Grunde geht es um die traditionellen
Rollen die in der südkoreanischen
Gesellschaft in Bezug auf Mutterschaft
und ehe immer noch existieren
[Musik]
man könnte nämlich sagen dass sich die
beruflichen und persönlichen Ambitionen
der jungen Frauen in diesem Land viel
schneller verändert haben als die
Wahrnehmung ihrer Rolle in der
Gesellschaft in Südkorea sind Kinder
einfach reine Frauensache und das ist
logischerweise nicht leicht mit dem
modernen Leben und den legitimen
persönlichen und beruflichen
Bestrebungen von 100.000 ja Millionen
von Frauen zu vereinbaren wir haben es
euch auf visuale Politik schon oft
gesagt das was zählt sind narrative und
nein wir reden hier nicht über das
hetero Patriarchat oder sowas sondern
über soziale Rollen die in der großen
Mehrheit des bestens bereits überwunden
sind eine Entwicklung die Südkorea und
Asien im allgemeinen noch nicht
absolviert haben und dann während er
natürlich noch die gehälterfrage der
Wunsch nach Karriere und die extrem
hohen Wohnkosten über die wir in
früheren Videos bereits gesprochen haben
tatsache ist dass die Summe all dieser
Gründe dazu geführt hat dass immer mehr
junge Frauen das Gefühl haben dass Ehe
und Mutterschaft eine unnötige Belastung
für sie sind oder vielmehr ein Problem
dem sie sich nicht stellen wollen tja
wollt ihr in diesem Zusammenhang eine
spektakuläre Zahl hören nun laut einer
Umfrage aus dem Jahr 2020 waren sage und
schreibe
42,5% der Südkoreaner in ihren 30ern
nicht verheiratet das sind 13% Punkte
mehr als noch 2010
Romantik boomt in Südkorea aber Heirat
ist nicht mehr das Ziel tatsächlich
handelt es sich bei 40% aller Haushalte
in Südkorea um Singlehaushalte und 2022
befand sich mit weniger als 192 000 die
Zahl der Eheschließungen auf ihrem
niedrigsten Stand seit 1970 und damals
hatte Südkorea eine viele kleinere
Bevölkerung in Südkorea sind junge
Frauen eben immer weniger dazu bereit zu
heiraten und alles auf sich zu nehmen
was dies in der Kultur und Gesellschaft
dieses Land Essen mit sich bringt und
ihr habt bereits gesehen dass es ohne
Heirat in Südkorea auch keine Kinder
gibt darüber hinaus ist Scheidung in der
koreanischen Gesellschaft ein absolutes
Tabu obwohl sie legal ist werden viele
Frauen die sich scheiden lassen in
irgendeiner Form diskriminiert auch wenn
Sie dank moderner koreanischer
Fernsehserien und Filme gesellschaftlich
immer mehr Akzeptanz finden dieser
gesellschaftliche Anpassungsprozess geht
aber sehr langsam vor sich zu langsam
und das bedeutet dass ich eine Frau sehr
wohl bewusst ist dass sie wenn sie
heiratet nach einer eventuellen
Scheidung eine schwere Zeit haben könnte
wenn die Dinge schief laufen das lässt
viele von ihnen heutzutage natürlich
noch mehr zögern zu heiraten aber das
ist noch nicht alles haltet euch jetzt
fest
[Musik]
denn es gibt sogar noch eine
Frauenbewegung die als die vier Neins
bekannt ist kein dating kein Sex mit
Männern keine Ehe und keine Kinder die
traditionelle Familie wird bei jungen
Menschen in diesem Land immer
unbeliebter und wie ihr seht hat diese
Art und Weise wie die Dinge geregelt
sind und laufen Konsequenzen und zwar
für die Zukunftsfähigkeit der gesamten
südkoreanischen Gesellschaft aber jetzt
wo ihr wisst wo die Hauptursachen für
dieses demografische liegen stellen sich
viele von euch vielleicht eine Frage was
um alles in der Welt tut die Regierung
um diese Situation zu lösen kann sie
überhaupt etwas tun nun die Wahrheit ist
ja sie haben bereits Maßnahmen ergriffen
und sie tun dies auch weiterhin aber man
könnte sagen dass im Grunde alles danach
aussieht als würde es sich um Akte der
Verzweiflung im Blindflug handeln also
wollte er hören was eigentlich der
größte Hammer an dieser ganzen
Geschichte ist nur und dann passt jetzt
gut auf
[Musik]
auf fliegen mit Kanonen feuern
eine Frage was wäre wenn ich euch
verraten würde das Südkorea in den
letzten 16 Jahren 200 Milliarden Dollar
für Maßnahmen zur Förderung der
Geburtenrate verpullert hat ohne dass
sie auch nur das Geringste erreicht
hätten denn 200 Milliarden Dollar später
befindet sich die Zahl der Geburten auf
einem historischen Tiefstand was
übrigens eine Warnung an alle Politiker
ist die denken dass diese Angelegenheit
mit einem Scheckbuch gelöst werden kann
nicht jedes Problem lässt sich unter
einem Haufen Geld begraben es hat sich
also herausgestellt dass der
südkoreanische Staat jedes Jahr etwas
12,5 Milliarden Dollar für die
geburtenpolitik vergoldet das entspricht
etwa den Budget dass ein Land die
Spanien jährlich für die Verteidigung
ausgibt und wie ihr sehen könnt war das
Ergebnis gleich null könnte es also sein
dass Südkorea das perfekte Beispiel
dafür ist dass die Geburtenrate nicht
mit staatlichen Geldern gefördert werden
kann nun vielleicht ja vielleicht haben
wir es hier mit dem wildesten Beispiel
zu tun dass wir zur Gesicht bekommen
können aber Pass ist nicht das
Schlimmste das Schlimmste ist dass sich
die Regierung weiterhin für diesen Weg
entscheidet obwohl sie selbst zugibt
dass er nicht funktioniert 31 August
2022 Korea verdreifacht babygeld nachdem
er seinen eigenen Rekord für die
niedrigste Geburtenrate der Welt
gebrochen hat um euch eine Vorstellung
davon zu geben wie schlimm die Dinge
wirklich stehen Präsident Dion hat
angekündigt dass er den bereits
bestehenden baby-check für die ersten
zwei Lebensjahre eines Neugeborenen
verdreifachen wird das entspricht einer
Erhöhung von 300.000 wollen die der
frühere Präsident Moschee in festgelegt
hatte auf eine Millionen worden das sind
etwas mehr als 750 € pro Monat und
machen wir uns nichts vor auch diese
Maßnahme wird einmal Ergebnis
wahrscheinlich nichts ändern
[Musik]
denn in erreichen Ländern wie Südkorea
hat das Kinderkriegen oder eben das
nicht kriegen mehr mit sozialen und
kulturellen Faktoren und weniger mit
wirtschaftlichen Problemen zu tun wenn
das Umfeld stimmt und die Menschen das
Gefühl haben dass sie geschützt und
ermutigt werden Kinder zu bekommen
werden sie auch dann Kinder bekommen
wenn man es ihnen verbietet mit Geld
einreisen allein kann man die
Geburtenrate nicht wirklich ankurbeln
aber jetzt haltet euch fest denn selbst
diese Maßnahme die sich wahrscheinlich
als genauso nutzlos wie die vorherigen
erweisen wird ist besser als andere
verrückte Ideen die sich südkoreanische
Politiker ausgedacht haben um dieses
Problem zu lösen einige davon sind so
abwegig dass man meinen könnte es würde
sich nur um Strohhalme Handeln an die
man sich aus Verzweiflung klammert ihr
nicht ihr denkt ich würde übertreiben
dann passt jetzt gut auf
[Musik]
vor einiger Zeit hat ein Dutzend
Parlamentarier einen Vorschlag
unterbreitet dass das Land mit
ausländischen Kindermädchen überschwemmt
werden soll die natürlich unter dem
Mindestlohn bezahlt werden okay
zugegeben das ist etwas was den Ländern
die Singapur bereits praktiziert wird
mit der Begründung dass die Bedingungen
dort immer noch viel besser sein als in
den Heimatländern der Kindermädchen
trotzdem hat das in Südkorea viel Kritik
hervorgerufen dort ist man dann doch
etwas soziale eingestellt
[Musik]
dann gab es noch den Vorschlag Männer
die vor dem 30 lebensjahr drei oder mehr
Kinder zeugen von der Wehrpflicht zu
befreien das Problem ist aber dass eben
nur Männer zum Wehrdienst verpflichtet
sind und was soll ich sagen egal wie
viele Männer bereit sind den lästigen
Militärdienst auf diese Weise zu umgehen
wenn es keine Frauen gibt die bereit
sind drei Kinder zu bekommen ist es eine
ziemlich nutzlose Maßnahme aber wartet
noch einen Moment denn jetzt kommt der
wirklich gute Teil
[Musik]
die beiden Dinge von denen ich euch
jetzt erzähle sind wahr geworden es
handelt sich um keinen Scherz schaut
euch einfach an ich bin Korea hat sie
Website zurück die Frauen im besten
Alter kartiert um Kinder zu bekommen
südkorea hat nach einem öffentlichen
Aufschrei eine staatliche Webseite
geschlossen auf der die Anzahl der
Frauen im gebärtigen Alter zwischen 15
und 49 Jahren nach Stadtbezirk und
Region angezeigt wurde die Nutzer
konnten nachsehen wie viele Frauen
zwischen diesen Altersgruppen in den
letzten 10 Jahren in ihrer Nachbarschaft
wohnten es handelt sich um eine Art
Bauer sucht Frau nur eben online und die
Frauen haben keinerlei Ahnung dass sie
für die Show überhaupt ausgewählt worden
niemand hat sie gefragt ob sie überhaupt
heiraten wollen es ist als hätte Rudi
Carrell Herzblatt und lass dich
überraschen in einer Show verspolzen
aber jetzt kommt das beste diese Show
wird von der Regierung gefördert und
finanziert na findet ihr das nicht auch
genial und selbst das ist nur die Spitze
des Eisbergs in südkoreal gibt es lokale
Regierungen die den Kauf von
ausländischen Ehefrauen subventionieren
ja ihr habt richtig gehört ich habe Kauf
von Frauen gesagt
Südkoreas kommunale Subvention ermutigen
Käufer ausländischer Beute Bräute aus
Usbekistan am teuersten mehr als 35
statt Verwaltung haben Verordnung
erlassen die heiratsbeihilfen für
Einheimische Männer vorsehen die mit
ausländischen Bräuten den Bund der Ehe
eingehen wir reden hier von einer ganzen
Versandhaus brautindustrie die ist in
Korea schon seit ein paar Jahren gibt
[Musik]
und in der Tat scheint sie sich
tatsächlich durchzusetzen selbst in Soul
gibt es zahlreiche Unternehmen bei denen
sich ein Mann eine Frau aus einem
Katalog aussuchen kann die Unternehmen
sorgen dann gegen eine bestimmte Gebühr
dafür dass diese Frau nach Südkorea
fliegen und den Auftraggeber heiraten
klar in Europa und den USA gibt es auch
sowas trotzdem hört es sich in diesem
Umfang für uns relativ verrückt an Asien
ist die Tradition arrangierte ihn jedoch
viel stärker verbreitet den Menschen
dort ist er das Konzept der
klischeehaften liebesheir fremd und
Südkorea ist zusammen mit Taiwan das
asiatischen Land in dem diese Praxis am
häufigsten vorkommt für die einen ist
dies ein klares Beispiel für
Menschenhandel für die anderen ist es
nichts anderes als eine Vermittlung wie
jede andere schließlich hat diese Art
von Tätigkeit sogar einen eigenen Namen
sie werden schlicht und einfach
Heiratsvermittler genannt in Südkorea
gibt es sage und schreibe 400 solcher
Unternehmen aber selbst wenn wir
moralische Erregungen mal beiseite
lassen ist es denn angemessen das
öffentliche Verwaltungen diese Art von
Geschäften mit bis zu 10.000 Dollar
subventionieren denn das ist genau das
was einige Gemeinden tun ja und das
Ergebnis das können wir dieser Grafik
perfekt entnehmen
wie ihr gesehen habt passt Südkorea ein
so großes geburtenproblem dass ich das
Land quasi auf dem Weg des Aussterbens
befindet ein Problem dessen Lösung weit
und breit nicht zu erkennen ist es wird
nur noch schlimmer immer mehr Frauen
lehnen Mutterschaft und ehe einfach ab
und das ist ein ernstes Problem in einer
Gesellschaft und unter Institutionen die
immer noch nicht in der Lage sind andere
Arten von Mutterschaft oder Familien
Rollen zu akzeptieren und die
öffentliche Politik anzupassen aber was
meint ihr dazu glaubt ihr das wird Korea
sein enormes demografisches Problem mit
anderen politischen Maßnahmen in den
Griff bekommen könnte ist das alte
Modell das besagt dass man einfach immer
mehr Geld verschenken muss um mehr
Kinder zu bekommen endgültig gescheitert
was haltet ihr von den Vorschlägen und
Maßnahmen die in Südkorea propagiert
werden damit mehr Kinder geboren werden
wie immer sind wir auch eure Diskussion
zu diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt
ich hoffe dass euch dieses Video
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht etwas
dabei gelernt haben falls ja gibt uns
bitte ein Leid als mit neuen Freunden
und vergesst nicht das aber mit
glücklichen um keines unserer Videos zu
verpassen natürlich wollen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen der Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut bis bald
[Musik]